and the smmes are great because you can
open the door with them you know they've
got 50 developer vacancies whatever it
may be uh I'm certainly not filling them
but um it's and you can ride those coils
and it's really really good in the boom
time but so much of that Tech Market is
reliant on Market confidence and funding
and so on so when that dries up you can
find yourself a little bit more exposed
and I think we found that this year when
the market was going great last year
just ignored it you don't care where the
deals were coming from you're just doing
doing placements celebrating posting it
on LinkedIn and like everyone does not
me but everyone else um and um you know
if I if I'd have sat there last year and
gone let's look at the diversification
of our client portfolio every everyone
laugh but we should have looked at the
divers so because because when that
funding dries up in that sort of space
we were a little bit more exposed than
we would have liked to have been